[Music]
how many of you are there not enough
need people abducted from or near STAR
Labs there's the potential purple
parademons okay
the demons must describe the scent of
the mother box they carry the people
away to find out what they know
so the 8mr be alive nine Oh ahead of
STAR Labs was taken as well you made it
so then there must Manas nearby I
plotted all the sightings of Metropolis
Gotham no pattern I can see the lines on
the map don't converge on land these
lead back to Braxton Island between the
two cities Gotham Harbor these are air
vents they only done to the town to
Metropolis project that was abandoned
this 49
[Music]
do you really think that oh wow they
just they really just vanish huh oh
that's rude I'm afraid of bugs
guns obnoxiously murder a kewpie it's
really cool you guys seem ready to do
battle and stuff but fulfills perón see
I've never done battle I've just pushed
some people run away save one save one
person Oh which one don't talk don't
fight get in get one out you know
okay
[Music]
thanks Alfred but I'll take it from here
do I know you
[Music]
[Music]
relative volumes what are we under right
now
Gotham are
you've got a team here
Superman you bring this team together
better than I ever could his strength
doesn't matter how strong you are or
what abilities you might be more human
than I am he lived in this world fell in
love a job despite all that power world
needs Superman on a team needs Clark
[Applause]
this is man's best hope done with the
modern world back to the dark ages and
the safety of holy fair
[Music]
go class what are you a believer
I believe there is a stranger comes to
this village from the sea it comes in
the winter when the people are hungry
brings fish he comes on the King tide
that was last night
they wanna add fealty those goodies
kilos of Delos icebergs in the harbor
four months since the last ship got
through
well this stranger doesn't come by ship
there are enemies coming from far away I
need warriors I'm building an alliance
and defend ourselves you should get out
can you at least point me to Atlantis
Arthur curry
also known as protector of the oceans
the Aquaman here you can tuck to fish I
know you have abilities I just don't
know what they are my special skills
include viola a web design fluent in
sign language gorilla sign language
silica based quartz and fabric Rajon
resistant heat-resistant yeah I do
competitive ice dancing what they use on
the space shuttle to prevent it from
burning up on re-entry I do very
competitive ice dancing whoever you're
looking for
[Music]
[Music]
you're the Batman
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team people with special abilities you
see I believe enemies are coming stop
right there
I'm in you are yeah I need friends
[Music]
what did you do this weekend ina me huh
nothing very interesting the world
remains in mourning after the death of
the Superman he said the age of heroes
who never come again it has to
[Music]
we don't have anymore time
[Music]
something is calling
don't let her kiss you
no language
[Music]
the Kryptonian
[Music]
which made this year
like all the others well this is the
days were month biggest concerns were
exploding windup penguins this is crazy
I'll say I think we're all gonna die
each of us in some way is held back
don't engage alone until this together
really cool you guys seem ready to do
battle and stuff I've never done that
relax Alfred I'll take it from here do I
know you
Superman was at least into the world
you don't save people
to see the best parts of themselves
are there recognized as well we don't
have to recognize
[Music]
which is had to save it
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough do
you really think that oh wow they just
they really just vanish huh oh that's
rude
you said you've come now that's hope
you're not too late
[Music]